This just reminds me of a little story time of how not a fairy tale,
how opposite from a fairy tale my life was in. In that time.
When we got married,
we didn't have enough money to have, like,
a big wedding,
so we just eloped.
So, like,
I have. I had, like,
a little dress that I bought just from a little store,
a little boutique here in Denver.
Like, he came with me to buy my dress.
Nobody was there.
We didn't have family.
I didn't have bridesmaids.
I didn't do any of the things that I wanted,
like, all the things that I dreamed of as a little girl.
But it was because,
you know, we were young and,
you know, he was unemployed,
and we were just gonna,
you know, get through it with love.
And we made a promise that our 10 year wedding anniversary,
we would have the wedding that I always dreamed of.
And we had 10 years to save up for it, and we were gonna do that.
And every time I wanted to save up for it, anytime I would, like,
like, I remember around, like, year 8,
I was like, hey,
we kind of get big tax returns.
Why don't we just save our next couple tax returns,
and then we can start planning?
I would love for my father to walk me down the aisle.
I would love to have the father daughter dance.
Like, all the things That,
you know, you promised me.
And I know, like,
in 10 years, our life still isn't where we thought it would be.
But can I at least get this?
Can I at least get the wedding that you promised me 10 years ago?
And I have faithfully been your wife
and done all the things that I needed to do. Well,
we did not save appropriately.
We did not have the wedding of my dreams.
And that was fine.
I was willing to put it off longer.
We did have a child with a disability in the middle,
and there was a lot going on in our life.
So I thought, okay,
maybe we could do it 11 year,
12 years, something else.
Um. But I wanted a special night out.
Well, after I had to book the babysitter,
and I made the reservations, and I planned the whole evening.
All he had to do is get dressed and show up on time.
And we lived in the same fucking house.
He was literally late.
He ended up, like,
doing dumb shit that day that I was like,
are you sure this is a good time to be doing that?
Cause we're going out later.
And I got told how controlling and shitty I was.
And then,
yeah, he realized he didn't have clean clothes or good clothes or.
I don't know, he wanted to feel special.
He wanted to get me something.
So, like, literally 30 minutes before The babysitter was gonna get there.
He ran to target to buy himself a shirt and then to get me flowers.
And so he walked in the door 30 minutes late for the date
cause we had reservations,
we had a babysitter.
I had, like, things timed and planned.
I put a lot of effort into this.
I, my heart was broken.
I saw these, like,
target flowers and I was like.
And I mean, I happily accepted them and went along with the night,
but I mean, it was just like,
there are those milestone moments that you look back and you're like,
yeah, that was one of the, like,
bricks coming down of that wall,
that thought that was holding me back between me and divorce,
you know?
So I totally understand the feeling of it
not even being close to the fairy tale you thought.
And I promise you, the thought and that feeling doesn't go away.
These people don't really change because why would they?
What incentive do they have to change?
You're doing everything right now,
receiving whatever bullshit they give you.
So why would they change?
That's not human nature to just be like,
I'm gonna make my life a little bit harder for no reason,
you know what I mean?
So if it's not in him to do it,
it's not in him.
And you can still get that fairy tale.
So I'm sending you love.